parents would be upset if their kid
cried and I would like run up to kids
that would cry after losses and commend
them you're showing me you care I think
being competitive is a remarkable gift
indifference is devastating I mean I
cried basically every day of my life
between 600 and 12 because I played
everything competed constantly and there
was not a time I lost between 600 and 12
where I didn't break into tears because
it hurt that much it hurt that much I'm
devastated watching our society try to
tell kids it doesn't matter attention is
the number one asset we recently met for
the first time you were kind enough to
swing by my launch of my fragrance next
chapter it smells remarkable everyone
thank you uh you know what the the
following day I thought to myself Gary
would be the perfect guest for Club 30
thank you for two reasons one I want to
get to know you even better but two
this is a great opportunity for our
listeners to hear your Insight on so
many things so thank you for being thank
you so much I'm humbled really but when
I watch you listen to you I feel like
there's so much passion in everything
you do where where is that coming from
you know I think I think I have very
strong Clarity you know the luck of the
draw of being an immigrant having very
little growing up with a mom who I think
was incredibly thoughtful
and you know just the Serendipity of the
way my life played out I I I feel like
I'm not confused and let me let me say
what I mean by that I don't
understand how a human that's listening
to this or that lives in the world
doesn't recognize how remarkable it is
to be a human there are incredible
challenges in being a human there's many
things always going on whether in the
macro or in one's individual status
today somebody
will go to the doctor and get diagnosed
with cancer terminal today somebody will
lose a loved one today there'll be macro
things going in the world everyone knows
that that being said in Reverse every
day that something atrocious doesn't
happen to you is actually the greatest
and so I've I'm incredibly driven by
gratitude every day I wake up and my
phone doesn't have I didn't have to be
woken up in the middle of the night of
something terrible and every day
something bad hasn't happened to the 10
or 15 people that mean the most to me I
genuinely not like the [__] you know
motivational quote on social media or on
your calendar I genuinely view that as a
epic thing I'm excited I'm on the
offense you know in general as a human
and so I'm very passionate I'm pumped
that I got to be a human I could have
been a
hippo you know it could have been a
flower like a ladybug like human is the
Apex of something that's alive and we're
also living in a Great era I know people
are very especially now there's a lot of
challenges going on if we just rewind
the clock 100 years from today the
second we're sitting here you know we're
on our way to going into we're in the
Roaring 20s and it seemingly is good but
the next 25 years the world is going to
be incredibly conflict with two world
wars life expectancy in its 50s and 60s
like we have it good not everyone listen
in right how is it good because
something bad might have happened they
might be an abusive relationship they
might be dealing with mental health
issues they may be dealing with health
issues I get that my push to everyone
who isn't dealing with something extreme
is choose to be optimistic versus
pessimistic and cynical and you will be
flabbergasted on how much more joy you
will have and so the reason I produce so
much content is I believe that people
who do see from a perspective of hope
and love and joy and good have a bigger
responsibility in our society right now
to start producing more content because
I believe that negativity and cynicism
and darkness is very loud and I feel
like light and happiness and joy they
keep it in their Circle they keep it
amongst their 12 friends and I I'm
willing to deal with the ramifications
of a public figure life and all the
judgment and the ridicule and
misunderstanding and all the lack of
privacy and all the things that come
along with it because I think it's my
responsibility that I got fortunate and
I don't love using lucky but in this
instance I'll say it lucky with the DNA
and the parents I had and I want to be
loud and I want every single person
who's listening right now to realize if
you want to find negativity in the world
it'll take you two seconds you can turn
on the news you can go on social and
find certain stuff but if you want to
find positivity you can do it in a
second you don't put on the news and on
social and digital you find people that
are pushing progress happiness
advancement offense and there are
millions of them and I just challenge
people to decide for themselves because
you find what you're looking for your
life is what you decide to look for I I
love this and and so my question you
came to the US at 3 years old yes so how
did your
upbringing everything shap you and and I
want to know when did you start to think
about mindset late um but early let me
explain so I think like for us two and
Dustin's in the room filming me for us
four in the room we were completely
shaped by our childhood DNA sure but
nature right and nurture and so I
believe I'm in a small group of people
and it's not that small 10 20% of the
world that is the most fortunate and
I'll say this very slow because I think
it may change the perspective of some
listening I believe the greatest way to
have the best situation to have the best
potential to have a good life is to be
born in the in this specific
circumstance to be born in a
circumstance with not a lot not a
wealthy family not a lot but Extreme
love and happiness in the household
because I believe what is happening and
I've I I know that about myself and I
watch it in a lot I basically for the
last 20 years I've been watching people
right that's why I was so all in on
social and was an investor in all those
platforms I believe that if you are
lucky enough to be born into a family
that is Happy genuinely that it's a joy
you know you can't there's going to be
conflict here and there but overall Net
score a joyous optimistic family and you
also don't associate that happiness with
the fact that you're rich right because
if you're born into a wealthy happy
family you as a child are formed of
course to believe there's a got to be a
variable there of the wealth driving
this Joy if you're born the way I was I
mean when I came to America and I I
remember this cuz by the time we got
here I was four and we lived there until
I was five and a half six I lived in a
studio apartment not much bigger than
the room we're in right now probably two
and a half times bigger tiny with five
to eight family members depending on
what was happening with our immigration
you know I I can't I can't even you
can't even comprehend how much of an
advantage it is for a child to not have
things but have pure love you're
unstoppable you never as an adult
associate happiness with money every
time I talk like this including this
podcast I will get comments in my social
saying yeah whatever like easy for you
to say you have money because they know
me today they don't know me from 22 to
30 when I never made more than $60,000 a
year they don't know me I wasn't public
the world didn't work that way so I mean
my upbring and then I also had a mom who
was very talented she did something very
smart she built incredible self-esteem I
thought it was the best but not entitled
and delusional so she grounded me a lot
it was also the 80s and she was from
Russia so I got a smack in the face at
times I think one of the issues with
modern parenting is we don't hold kids
accountable we do instill delusion I
believe eth police trophies have ruined
the world we've demonized losing I think
one of the great Advantage a lot of
athletes have
is no matter when they start
sport there's nothing Mommy and Daddy
can do on the ice or the court in the
classroom they can literally go and
fight the teacher after the report card
and change the grade but on the ice if
you lost 42 you lost 42 and and I think
that's a big deal yeah you learn a lot
when you win but you learn even more
when you way more you learn so much so
it's such an important part of growing
up playing sports or whatever you do
losing teaches you
he gives you
motivation it's a good thing oh and you
know my my number one thing to parents
is show me someone who's a poor Sport
and I'll show you someone I want to get
to know and parents would be upset if
their kid cried and I would like run up
to kids that would cry after losses and
commend
them you're showing me you care I think
being competitive is a remarkable
gift indifference is
devastating I mean I cried basically
every day of my life between 6 and 12
because I played everything competed
constantly and there was not a time I
lost between 6 and 12 where I didn't
break into tears because it was it hurt
that much it hurt that much and and I I
I I'm devastated watching our society
try to tell kids it doesn't matter
meanwhile they tell them grades in
school does matter when in reality the
day they become 22 it's the reverse
competition matters in real life and
grades matter zero in real life and so I
think I think you know it was a huge
shaper of mine plus where you know we
moved from Queens to New Jersey I grew
up in a 1980s Edison New Jersey
childhood which meant my mom had no idea
what I was doing she knew I was in the
general area and was schol back then is
all your friends parents were your
parents too it was communal right it was
a different it was different better
behave you better behave at all times
but you know you know we we just lived
outside we you know we got into fights
we played Sports we sold lemonade and
did business ask you business when was
your first six six seven I sold lemonade
we we also you know I didn't just do the
soft lemonade thing we did shoveling
snow when it would snow a lot of my
friends in the neighborhood would go
sledding make snowmen I grabbed a shovel
and started ringing doorbells ma'am
would you like me to shovel your
driveway for $5 driving that had no
that's just that goes back to what I'm
so fascinated about humans one of the
things I talk about for a lot of people
here who are discovering this content I
I think you need to fight to find
yourself here's what I mean by that I
have no idea Henrik it wasn't like that
was just DNA right like I didn't I was
seven not like was it you want to make
money early it was it you know it's
funny and this is a huge Advantage for
this is why I think entrepreneurship is
confusing right now I think in the last
10 15 years entrepreneurs have become
more relevant Fame this is crazy to me I
didn't you know I was 31 years old
before I made a video I grew up my whole
I was an adult before it even compreh it
didn't even cross my mind that humans
would know who I was I thought people
would know me in the wine business in
the in the business World sure because I
was in that but the thought that on the
walk here somebody might say hi or a
selfie it it businessmen weren't famous
that wasn't a thing no to me it was and
this is and what I'm scared about is
people are now chasing the money people
want to be entrepreneurs for the fame
and the money the problem is
entrepreneurship is hard it's really
hard and it's extremely lonely you know
you're at the top of an organization and
everything's your fault and everything's
your responsibility it's like being a
parent it's all fun in games until
you're a parent you know every everybody
goes through this they have all sorts of
Judgment of their parents until they
become a parent and they're like wait a
minute and so anyway no back going back
Henri the I just have no idea it was who
I was in the same way that I I look at
athletes I look at musicians I look at
artists I teachers stay-at-home parents
like my mom was
destined genuinely to be a stay-at-home
mother and like raise a family and like
I'm the great beneficiary of that I
think a lot of people
compromise their their greatest skills
because they don't think they can make
money in it I think about all my friends
who were remarkable at video games when
it wasn't clear that video games were a
business and so they didn't they thought
they had to get a real job but had they
stayed and played video games they might
be the Tony Hawk of video games today
the way it played out sure and so I
think people need to chase
passion and then live within the means
of what that Financial outcome is and I
think sometimes it's like chasing
passion doesn't mean you have a specific
thing in mind but it's a way of doing
and what I mean by that is like it could
be uh wanting to be helpful yeah or
wanting to solve problems yeah and and
figuring out like that's my and to your
point I love solving problems so that
can mean I love what you're saying so
that can mean oh you're destined to
become an engineer exactly cuz Engineers
solve problems oh you're destined to be
a therapist cuz that Sol
oh you're destined to be a guidance
counselor in a middle school oh you're
destined to be an entrepreneur because
you're going to create a product that
solves a like I like that I agree with
that I think that's a I think what that
does for people is it gives them a
little bit more room to figure
themselves out because you have to take
the first step because you'll never know
how to take the second one unless you
take the first one which is leaning into
a process or a way of being rather than
a specific thing I think a lot of people
listening to this will like this analogy
I love sports obviously I'm establishing
that in my office I talk about to
employees
I just recently had some young man work
for me and he was doing a certain role
and I said hey you're an extrovert
you're not cross your teas and Dot your
eyes you're doing a cross your tees and
Dot your eyes job now you need to get
out of this we and I said look my job as
CEO is to put players in a position to
succeed very hardcore Sports analogy the
most fascinating thing I watch in sports
is the variable of a head coach because
it's you know ESP especially within a
within a season anytime a team in any of
the four major sports fires a manager or
head coach in season even if I don't
follow that team I kind of keep a little
eye on the next month of what that team
does because it speaks to the actual
variable of that person right it is the
same players it's not the next season
you know I think you know and you know
this HRI I think fans are naive a team
seemingly is the same as last year but
many things happen everybody's a year
older anything can happen and by the way
one player let alone three different
players changes everything potentially
especially if one of those three players
is special or the reverse you get rid of
one cancerous cynical player changes the
entire locker room so inseason coaches
coming is like one of my biggest
Fascinations as a CEO I stay up at night
thinking about is Dustin doing the
single best thing he could be doing in
this organization both for the
organization and for DUS and for Dustin
right cuz if you do it for Dustin then
it will happen for the organization do
you view your companies uh from a
sports standpoint almost do you see
yourself as a coach more as a coach than
as a boss 100% I see myself first of all
I think that almost every CEO and boss
has it wrong I even it was funny when
you even said the word of what happened
in my stomach it didn't feel good
because I think the world has defined
boss as person that tells you what to do
person that's keeping you
accountable I I feel that I work for
every employee and I really show up that
way and I feel like I have to dictate
the strategy right so yes I do think
more of myself as a coach as a parent as
a guidance counselor as an older brother
feels very appropriate uh I am the
oldest in my family and I was in a a
family where it was again it was an
immigrant family so my mom I mean from
the time I mean from the time I was six
I remember my mom saying like you have
to take care of your sister you know
like you're out there at 8 years old
you're eight you're you're a child
you're a baby eight and you know I'm
keeping an eye on her and I got to fight
if somebody makes fun of her like real
[__] and so yes I I I I do view it that
way so mindset obviously plays a huge
part in your life in your business yes
at what point did you start to reflect
on your mindset for me as an athlete
obviously I understood I would say
around 14 15 16 I started to see just
better performance when I committed more
time to my mental side of it the
preparation the um consistent time you
know going into a game or practice just
getting ready so I I start to really
understand if I could feel the
difference see the difference that's I
think the time when I started to reflect
on my mindset when when was I I love I
can't believe you brought that up so my
answer is interesting I think at least
I'm fascinated this is the actual answer
I flirted with it very lightweight at
around the same time 14 to 17 High
School flirted didn't understand it the
only thing I knew was this is weird
I'm playing High School different than
the other 250 kids in my class I feel no
peer pressure I could give two shits if
I'm picked on or don't have social
status I had I I had a very outgoing and
like kind of am who I am personality so
I was very liked but I did something in
the 90s in New Jersey if you weren't
picking on kids you weren't popular and
I wasn't willing to compromise I wasn't
willing to go to the next tier of
popularity because I wasn't willing to
[__] on kids in my class and and I
worked on and I would choose going to a
baseball card show and selling on a
Friday night instead of going to a cool
party that I was invited to that I
should have felt cool about I was only
20% of the class invited I would go I
would work at my dad's liquor store on
the weekends instead of hanging out I
was so
different and I sensed it but it was
very hazy about 30 about 20 years later
when I was 35 I'd been putting out
content for long enough telling people
starting in 2006 78 YouTube Facebook
Twitter do this do this do this this is
how you get more followers this is how
you get more people to buy from you on
email and I was putting out all this
content and I started realizing a lot of
people were not doing
it and I started getting fascinated of
why and that's when I had the early
epiphanies of like oh the whole world is
built on self-esteem you're either
confident or you're insecure and then a
million other variables of how that
happens and I started to my content
changed the first five years of me being
a businessman content it's very tactical
set up this website post at this
time and then you could you can start to
see after I started to get like and I
started reading the DMS and they're like
hey but if I post what if I don't like
the way I look and I'm like wo
right oh like my husband doesn't think I
should be doing this I'm like o right
like you know and by the way my
childhood was not all roses my mom was
incredibly optimistic my dad was
incredibly
pessimistic you know multiple and most
of my relatives including my mom's side
were pessimistic they grew up in the
Soviet
Union they always thought there was a
conspiracy you know I get it at the time
I didn't get it I would judge my uncles
my grand mom like I was like why is
everyone so negative like now I'm like
wait a minute they lived in the worst
place in the world at the time well
mindset is a tool we don't use mindset
as a tool to deal with the great times
like whoever thinks like I got to spend
more time on my mindset when
everything's going great mindset is a
tool well real quick though real quick I
apologize this is where gratitude and
appreciation is the tool right so like
think about brother think about how I
started the opening of this podcast it's
on an everyday basis this morning this
morning while brushing my teeth and
listening to Boomer talk about the Jets
and the Rangers I was like man good all
right thank you yeah it's a good like
real talk and by the way it's practice
one thing I've by the way step three
first I didn't understand like I just
said then I started understanding now
I'm going into a third phase where I'm
trying to tell people friends first even
like dust like the the I'm starting to
realize oh [__] I practice Yeah I say to
myself you are lucky this is a great day
mhm
like I have you want to hear something
insane that I would tell everyone
especially people of any level of status
I believe the single reason I am joyous
is because I have no attachment to my
professional and financial success I
have I feel like zero of my identity is
the Gary ve or the businessman it is
completely and utterly baked into my
self-worth is baked into how I feel
people feel about me based on how much
they know me yesterday what you two
thought about me is going to be was very
low on a mattering to me it is now grown
after this hour but Dustin matters a ton
to me he's been around me a ton my
sister more so it's just a pecking order
so I think for a lot of people if you're
a somebody did something at a Jets game
this weekend and I they got introduced
to me and they told me their full
profession in the intro hey John
Thompson doctor at this like and I'm
like you know I I take not yeah I think
about that I'm like I see he that's his
validation and I think about it like you
know listen we we can't go through this
podcast without talking about how
handsome Henrik is right like I I it's
actually written into the is it yeah but
but it's funny I'm going to use it as
something I talk a lot about I worry
that parents give validation to their
children around grades cuz it's a very
fake system I worry that parents get
validation on looks you know if a child
is told and there's there's a small
percentage of people like Henrik who are
just born attractive and it's going to
be a constant theme in their life and
especially for young women you know you
think about that you know then all of a
sudden in your 30s and your 40s and your
50s and your 60s it it I am curious
about how people validate themselves is
it school is it money is it zip code is
it the car you drive is it how you look
is it what you accomplish on the ice is
accomplish followers like I mean it it's
a very big deal and I think about it a
lot yeah I guess I think both things are
true so like obviously pra you're at an
elevated level of gratitude and
appreciation and maybe in your words you
go on the offensive right every day on
that I think when you first find those
tools it's not because things are you
got an eighth place trophy it's because
you lose and you have lesson right and
you think how do I deal with this how do
I how do I love myself when I just lost
this thing or got a bad grade and so
that I think there's a correlation
between how early we adopt those tools
and start practicing and and how adverse
our life is how many challenges do we
have to face and who is around you to
contextualize the failure yeah yeah that
would actually be my next question how
important is your surroundings in terms
of how you feel and and uh mindset how
do how do you keep a great mindset how
important is your team around you I
would argue that there's a level of
guilt that I walk around with every day
that I got the super mom and others
didn't and one person that didn't was my
dad and I love my grandma Esther but and
by the way I knew her mom my great
grandma Ana there was a lot of
negativity and so the insanity of the
difference of seeing my parents and my
dad gave me a ton of weapons meaning he
gave me a ton of good stuff my
competitive my mom's pretty competitive
too she likes to hide it but my dad's
really competitive and work ethic I mean
my dad came to this country and I
basically didn't see him for the first
10 years he established us you know um
but the surroundings is the whole ball
game it's the whole ball which is why
I'm with the level of guilt that I walk
around I believe that's another reason
I'm so compelled to make content I feel
like you know yesterday I walked out of
a meeting and this 15-year-old kid came
up to me he like Gary you love your
stuff selfie and it was funny like where
my brain goes I'm like man I don't know
if that kid is got great situation at
home or not great situation at home but
I'm really pumped that he watches my
videos not because I necessarily need it
of course it feels nice you're a human
like I'm a human but [__] like there are
so many people that don't have a
positive influence and a decoder of the
macro in their lives and so happy you
know we demonize social media and
Society now for all of its but all that
social media is is a mirror of society
they're social media is empty it's an
empty vessel it's not the news the news
programs social media is US social media
is us and so I'm so happy that I mean
and I get this by the way I get it every
day Henrik you know how you walk around
this town like you know as someone who
is very affected by Athletes Performance
and like the joy it brings me in the
escapism that Sports is you know how
like how many people ask like thank I
assum you know I just know this to be
true how many people thank you for that
Stanley Cup run or your career it feels
nice they're like thank you like it
happens like to me people saying thank
you for like putting a video that
changes the perspective that it you're
helping people it's why we love music
and sports we get to escape Our Truth
and get joy right for me I help people
my content is focused and by the way
there are many many people out there
like myself and by the way for everyone
who's listening if like if you're like
what do I want to do what am I
passionate about if you're actually
happy just make videos about why what's
your routine what do you do but man
Henrik surroundings is everything and I
would say if your surroundings aren't
great starting to limit your time with
people that are negative is the
practice just like I practice in the
morning brushing my teeth I'm like
you're lucky today it's a good day and
not like again it's I think sometimes
people see this stuff and they think
it's dorky or like I think it's the most
real I think it's like doing push-ups
and then the limiting of negativity if
you're watching the news constantly
you're going to be upset if you're if
you're you know if your really affects
you it really affects you if your mother
is negative you can't like it's probably
not ideal to cut your mother out of your
life and I know that a lot of people
have asked their mother to go to therapy
in this and they won't I get that but
you don't need to talk to her four times
a day either and listen to her vent
you're allowed to protect yourself and
say to your mom we're going to do this
once every two days now you're loud
you're in control of breaking the
pattern everyone who's listening is in
control actually MH like I always tell
people complaining is like a funny game
like the only people that listen to you
complain is other complainers or people
that have to because they're your loved
ones right like I think you're in
control you it's funny with you know
talking about the part of the world
you're from I literally on stage say all
the time I'm like what do you want to
complain about you don't like your job
you can quit I understand that you have
a mortgage in this but you can live
under less means you can buy less
clothes you can take different
Transportation you can not take a
vacation that year you know like you can
do something to fight for your happiness
cuz I mean it you are allowed to move to
Toronto sure you're allowed like you're
so lucky my family wasn't Russia was a
jail the USSR was a jail from 1917 in
1989 you weren't allowed to leave the
country for vacation so like we're
fortunate and I think that's how I think
about it what's more important to you I
think I know the answer but I still I
wrote it you wrote it down so you can
ask what's more important to you success
or happiness oh happiness because
happiness is success I think we need to
redefine success you know you know it's
funny you ask me was it money it sure
wasn't and and like that was weird to me
for a while as a kid I would sell
baseball cards I would would work but I
would get the money and I would put it
back into the business right like I
would get money with selling baseball
cards I would buy more baseball cards
like I didn't want the cool jacket I
definitely didn't want Jordans cuz I was
a Knicks fan I would never wear them you
know like like you know like I you know
there was very few things I bought as a
child like I didn't want stuff stuff is
not interesting to me I love when people
are passionate about stuff when I think
about you Henrik from afar especially
with like you know even like watching
you set up the Aesthetics here I pay
attention to that stuff I'm like man of
course he likes fashion like he's visual
right like like I I think that's cool
I'm
not but I you know uh fancy cars I'm
always scared is that person buying a
fancy car to close the gap on insecurity
and they want to show people they made
it or did they grow up passionate about
the cars they understand the horsepower
they you know with wine for me I will
buy expensive wine I don't do it for the
flex I do it because I spell my whole
life learning about it I'm interested in
it I'm curious last night I ordered a
Cita Creek which is Washington State's
best Cabernet with my friend Craig I was
just curious how it
tasted can you tell our listen listeners
a little bit about your history with
wine yeah so my dad yeah my dad you know
lived the American dream went from a
stock boy in a liquor store in Clark New
Jersey to eventually buying his own
liquor store in New Jersey in
Springfield I was firstborn oldest son
only son you know only kid that was born
in the Old Country so it was very
Merchant son so very cliche at 14 I
started stocking the shelves like I live
that life that I think we've heard those
stories from others somewhere around 16
cuz the store was in Springfield New
Jersey which means on one side it was
like Union Elizabeth very blue collar on
the other side of the store was Short
Hills Milbourne Summit Livingston bougie
yeah my dad was in the liquor business
he was a liquor and beer guy
I'm a watcher as I've been explaining in
this podcast so the Summers and the
weekends I'm working I'm like people are
asking for this wine stuff and they're
asking for you know I was very
businessyoutube in one moment a man
comes in and it's this story is hazy to
me meaning I remember the moment but I
don't remember exactly what the man said
I don't even really fully remember what
he looks like it's one of those you
remember what you feel but you know and
he goes hey I'm looking for this this
and this and at this point I kind of
knew what Opus One and shatow Le fit
were and I was like we don't have it I
was like let me try to get got into
talking to
him and he's like yeah like I'm building
my
collection that was it the man said said
I'm building my collection I just moved
into Short Hills I have a wine room I'm
building my collection and I was like
people collect wine and I was Full Court
trading cards do you know how many Brian
leech 1990 rookie cards I have like how
many like a thousand actually yes yes
like I was Full Throttle like that 88
Olympic team RoR and leech when they did
a special on them and this was pre-
internet so you didn't know I didn't
know that they were going to be like I
was already Rangers I became a Rangers
Fan 86 when they made that huge run and
they lost in the Conference Finals to
this rookie
goenda and I was like this guy he's not
going to be
good anyway that was when I completely
fell in love the 88 Olympics came right
behind that and the big feature these
young kids could they do it 1980 was
only eight years earlier so could we do
it we got blown out got killed by the
Russians but leech and RoR were on that
team and so those were my guys and then
obviously that became the core team that
won the cup finally in ' 94 anyway I was
like people collect wine and literally
King from that
day 16
until I went full until 36 when I went
full-time into Vayner media my marketing
company I started with my
brother and left day-to-day running my
dad's wine store for him those next 20
years of my life I spent 95% of my
energy on building that wine business
and learning about wine so you're an
expert I I am an expert by the way that
people Define like I can speak to wine
at an incredibly high level I can taste
wine out of a brown paper bag and likely
tell you a definitely several things
about it I'm not like those
documentaries you've seen like Master SS
where like they like yeah I can't I'm
not I'm I'm the level below that I can
drink I can get pour a brown paper bag
and be like this is p Noir from France
maybe even this vintage and then you
pull it out you're like holy [__] like I
know it that well did you watch the sour
grapes of course like everything like
amazing amazing that was an amazing like
and then and then Bottle Shock and like
all those things like um you know I wine
was my life for 20 years I I still you
know it's funny when I left it because
it was my life oh I'm actually I'll ask
you this question about 5 years after
leaving and I'm still active I'll write
today's winetext.com
I'll write it for we have this cool
service where you get a text and if you
want it you get you just reply one two
three it's like frictionless I'll
literally write the copy for it today so
I'm still involved but when I but very
tangent when I left I about two three
years later I Started Loving wine again
you know it's kind of like I think about
athletes I'm like I wonder H as as time
goes from your retirement do you watch
do you watch the game differently
because when you're in something it's
different yeah and I get more joy with
wine today than I did 20 years ago I I
totally understand that yeah first year
out of retirement it was kind of weird
to watch a game brought up a lot of
emotions feelings should I play one more
or I think step by step you start coming
back
to watching the game as a fan again cool
and you stopped relating to yourself and
I still do that when I analyze the game
because I bring out my own experience um
but I remember that first year out of
retirement yes it was weird and at times
a little hard because it was such a big
part of my life such a long time right
of course but then what 3 years out now
I I I really enjoy it I mean I always
been a hockey fan which is huge and you
know this tell people at home a lot of
guys are not fans of the sports they
play true yeah it was their way out it
was their way to money success
opportunity and other guys love the
sport more than you know I I I know
American football the best and I do
think I have a different experience
watching Jets football than Knicks and
Rangers and Yankees because I understand
it so deeply and I think one of the cool
things that former athletes have when
they watch sports when they're able to
transition back to fan is they enjoy it
a lot because they actually really see
things we can't see you know you you
like if the announcer doesn't get to
saying that the defenseman should have
come in on that play you're capable of
knowing that and that makes it more
joyous and I I I find that it's really
back to actually this is a fun topic to
talk about here for me wine American
football um Collectibles trading cards
sneakers uh nft like Collectibles um are
great Joys because I know them deep I
think more people going deeper into the
things they like is something I think
more people should do like if you
collect watches
now spend an extra hour a day at night
instead of watching a Netflix show watch
YouTube videos about watches like going
deeper into passions I think is a really
interesting topic I've been marinating
on yeah I saw I saw something the other
day which is a simple stat which said if
you spend that one extra hour for 60
days you'll be in the top desile of
knowledge of a thing of a thing wow and
to me that's fast that is fast you know
and I've been thinking about this
especially towards the end of my career
and after my re
having a really strong passion for
something it's not a guarantee right I
think there's a lot of people that
they're still looking for it I I felt
very fortunate to find my passion at age
six yeah my passion was to play hockey
my sports early on but hockey became
very clear to me so he guided me yeah
throughout my life and that that's the
biggest thing I want for my kids now
just to find a passion you want them to
be curious yeah cuur by the way that's a
word can we talk about that word I think
curious might so I created this uh
Pokemon meets Sesame Street intellectual
property three years ago called V
friends and these characters there's
about 250 of them it's my Marvel it's my
Disney and I'm building it out YouTube
kids trading cards pins nfts uh you know
I'm already starting to plan an
amusement park hopefully in the next
decade like really in it a kids book
coming out next year it's really fun I'm
really living a Jim Henson Walt Disney
life it's super neat and I think
actually it will be what I do for the
rest of my life and so I'm really in it
anyway the reason I did it was I want
kids and parents to learn to lean into
certain attributes for example I believe
one of the biggest issues in the world
is lack of
accountability I believe if you realize
most things are actually your fault you
actually become happy not the reverse so
accountable ant is this incredibly fun
character I want to develop but it's
funny you just said that I'm starting to
fall in love with the Curious crane you
know the crane the bird
I keep looking at the trading card I
keep because I basically spend my
daydreaming and nights and sometimes
evenings developing these characters you
know what is the optimistic otter going
to be about what is the you know
generous Geral going to be about like
literally storytelling it's really
creative and I'm enjoying it but it's I
can't it's really cool that you just
said this because I can't get out of
this last month I've been looking at
this damn Crane and I'm like are you
know what it is I'm looking at all of
them and I'm like which one of you is
going to change the world I I think
about that I'm like is patient Panda
going to teach the world patience cuz
you want to talk about something that
[__] people up lack of patience leads
to bad behavior yeah right which is
grounded in insecurity you want to
succeed so fast to prove to everybody
you're good so I think about patience a
lot I even made two characters patient
Pig and patient Panda you know I believe
in but curious It's I'm pumped you
brought that up I do think that most of
us are not talking about curiosity as a
superpower enough and all of the parents
listening if you see that you have a
curious kid you need to become a
cheerleader of that if they want to cook
one weekend let's go if they want to
rock climb let's go if they want to pick
up a Guitar cool if they're asking you
about the Japanese whiskey you're
drinking not yet kid but let me tell you
about it you know like I do think
Curiosity has a real play in happiness
and I've been thinking about it a lot I
think right now the world is in this
revert to Norm mode which is like I'm
going to tell you how it is like don't
ask until like things get better like
this is just how it is and this is I
think these moments when the world feels
Bleak and and pessimistic is when
curiosity as a superpower gets us out I
like that right I really like that
brother I really I think you know look I
think about the people who wouldd be
listening to this and obviously a lot of
love to the man here with us and I think
about like what's the profile what are
they thinking about and you know one of
the great things about having all those
SP followers that you mentioned in the
beginning is reading the DMS the reason
I'm you know people are like why are you
so early on stuff like how' you know Tik
Tok or this or I'm like cuz I'm
listening I'm paying attention like why
why everything is why why and that goes
by curiosity why are people wearing you
know remember like 3 four years ago when
almost everybody wore tight jeans and
then like baggie came and like why do
men wear nail polish now more often and
why and why and why and why and I think
I think there's a lot of power to that
why and I think it also is grounded a
little bit in in not having as much fear
I think the world is very aggressively
selling fear even parenting if you think
about how parents predominantly parent a
kid they try to scare them out of doing
things right it's a very like don't do
that you're going to you know like they
they fear stop yourself sometimes that's
right I can cat myself yeah all of us
stop saying stop that's right don't do
that that's right all of us and listen I
get it you love them more more than
breathing I mean the it's the ultimate
love for anyone who's listening who
doesn't have that yet it is the ultimate
love I do think though that parents have
to catch themselves because these kids
are getting fed fear everywhere fear at
school fear in like and now what's
unfortunate is we are living through an
era where governments are governing
around the world both sides of the
political party in the US and everywhere
else I'm very into geopolitics from
India to Brazil to it is fear and so you
this goes back to the Inner Circle I
think everyone here needs to find a
source of offense and optimism and
happiness whether that is other human
beings which I always think is the best
way but you might do it yourself through
exercise meditation right therapy you
know I'm so happy we're finally here
that we can like I 20 years ago I'm not
saying that out loud it was taboo yeah
stigma it was stigma it was you need to
you're broken that's right yeah I'm so
pumped run this one cuz I believe the
brain is the game you know I believe the
operating system of us is how we feel
about ourselves and you know these are
important conversations we're having
yeah and gratitude I mean you started
the show talking a lot about gratitude
and it's funny
how how we think will change everything
literally every experience everyday
experience will the the outcome of that
will start with how we choose to think
right and
and I think the last couple years I went
more from performance focused to just
how how do I feel more
gratitude and uh I feel like my focus is
way more towards happiness it's good uh
I'm happy great feeling and and and you
should H like in do you know that
there's 735 million people that don't
have access to water clean water 700 35
million
10% of the earth can't get to clean
water within a day right we get so
caught up in our real lives I mean like
like you you are so
fortunate you know as long as everyone
is healthy everything that you worked
hard for has created a very special life
and like it's awesome and you were born
at the right time like we could have all
been born in 1643 we could have been
born in 1801 right you could have been I
mean going back to what I said earlier
we're not far removed from our great
grandparents think about this if you're
born in Europe in
1901 right you have World War I you have
World War II you have a genocide of Nazi
Germany and you're 45 years old and
you've lived through all that you black
plague you like the Great Depression
like right I mean we're just incredibly
fortunate most of us and and so please
everyone cuz inevitably something bad
will happen unfortunately for all of us
most people live a life unless you're
the unfortunate one who dies early which
is terrible but most of us will go
through very hard heartache of losing
the closest people to us definitely who
are older than us losing parents is
[__] horrible if you love them and
everyone loves their parents even when
it's [__] up you know what I mean like
so I think on the days that are good
really try to start enjoying them
because if you're complaining about like
your boss is a DI
or or the Rangers lost to the blue
jacket like you know like like like you
got to you got to put it in perspective
we need better perspective did you
prioritize the same things
today as you did let's say 10 years ago
yes same thing same thing 10 years ago
20 years ago 47 um 27 young yes same
things I I've been pretty much since I
would say
202 like right out of school I basic so
I hated school and I couldn't wait to be
an entrepreneur and I was like you know
probably since I was 11 I was like when
I'm 22 like that's how I thought so I
was so happy that first day of work and
basically I already knew I was going to
be successful I was too talented you
know unlike Sports this is why I hurt
for some athletes and you're going to
I'm going to actually ask you a question
who was the most talented player coming
up your life that got hurt by
injuries that you know would have been
an NHL Superstar but you remember them
getting hurt or so give it some thought
but unlike athletes when you're a
businessman and you've recognized you're
extremely
talented again unless you have a very
serious health situation you are going
to be successful unlike I'll use
basketball because it pops to mine Greg
Odin who was the number one pick in the
NBA like would have been a very
successful basketball player but his
knees did not hold up right H anybody
come to mind well I I just remember not
so much injuries it was more their
mindset well that happens all the time I
remember at 13 14 15 a couple of guys
they were so talented and I I thought to
myself there's no way they won't be inl
are not going to play for the national
team in the NHL and then 3 years later
it was fast too it was well that was
that era that's right you know you need
to
commit there's guys there that that
stands out and and I remember thinking
back oh wow I really thought that guy
would be like one of players by the way
that's why that's why I use Sports as an
analogy for everything I tried to bring
up one where he could say you know
obviously henrik's a gracious man he's
not going to call out those humans I
wanted him to give love to some guy who
might hear this and say [__] I would
have you know like the injury stopped
him it wasn't mind to henrik's point and
I want everybody to listen to this in
sports all of us that are close to it I
have a sports agency we rep football
players UFC fighters baseball we almost
got to hockey a couple years ago in a
merger but we'll get there eventually
anyway nonetheless we all know if we're
close to it how many people don't
succeed because of Mind in life it's
more hidden in sports this is why I love
sports it suffocates all of it it's
black and white in life you can make
pretend that it wasn't you but it was
you it was your mindset you had the
talent you could have been a great CEO
you could have been one of the SE sweet
Executives for Coca-Cola you could have
been a great engineer do you ever read
that book George Lois um great advice
for people who work hard it's basically
now everybody says hard work beats
Talent it's become like a tech but that
I I really believe that right which is
you can make a brand as an entrepreneur
around hard work and and not have the
the Deep depth of experience to take on
hard work is not subjective and it's not
debatable like either you do 100
push-ups or you do 10 right either you
put in the 10 hours of hard work or you
put in six now there are many people
right now talking to us in their car or
while they're running they like yeah but
you got to work smart and they're right
there are people that
work hard can come in a lot of just like
you made that great Point earlier hard
could come in different factors there
are a lot of people who work 13-hour
days doing hard labor and it might not
be the most strategic work that that
person could be doing but work ethic is
a huge Val variable it's a huge variable
in life yeah hey you brought up V your
sports and I were talking about this
beforehand I feel like the pivot there
was probably obvious from the media
company which is like you saw that but
what I want people to hear your answer
to Is this which is you know you have a
successful business and then you look at
oh I think the the agency for somebody
out there thinks I want to be an agent
yeah or I want to start an agency yep a
lot of people who I talk to think like
well I can't do that because CA and W
are already there like how am I going to
beat them yeah right tell us how you you
go into a space where all the signs say
no like it's already done you know
there's nothing new Under the Sun how
does an
entrepreneur get past that initial her
um talent and strategy first it was a
story of joy and sucess being defined as
happiness my brother has Crohn's disease
he had a tough spell in his mid-20s and
lay I'm sure laying in that hospital bed
he said what am I doing with my life and
he decided he wanted to be happier and
he decided that the marketing company we
were building was successful but it
wasn't making him happy so he decided
and said to me he wants to leave and
start a sports agency wants to be an NFL
agent and of course you know I'm the
older brother by 11 years so I'm like I
want to support him blindly I was like
[__] now I got to do this whole agency
Thing by myself and of course my brain
goes to where I'm at I'm like well let's
become the biggest and he's like whoa
whoa whoa like I'm doing this for
lifestyle a little bit more I'm like I
don't care you want me involved we're
you I was like but we we we we found our
balance nonetheless the CAA WME thing is
a great call out I love competing and
when you love competing and you love the
game you may hate to lose but you have
to respect the outcome so I think a lot
of entrepreneurs hate on fellow
entrepreneurs and it drives me crazy I
understand it but but for me the answer
to your question this is for everyone
listening no matter what you do
just because ice
spice and cardi B and Nicki Minaj are
successful female rappers has zero to do
with your ability to become a successful
or sexy red sexy red and Ice spice did
not get stopped by cardi B and Nicki
Minaj no one on earth no Organization no
person is actually stopping you from
your thing the world is abundant there
was no part of me that was I was like oh
my God it's impossible of course I knew
it would take us 10 years to build a
reputation to allow us to get to the
number one pick and because CIA would go
into the living room and say we've
repped the last 50 you know and we would
be like hey we we know marketing like I
knew that was you know a knife to a
gunfight at first but here we are 8 nine
10 years later and we're starting to get
very different outcomes and athletes and
so it's just putting in the work it's
not saying no right to your point a lot
of this talk has been about mindset if
you've said no about anything then that
means it's already over you're actually
right it's over if you say
maybe it becomes a whole different life
and so CAA WME didn't scare me but I
respect the piss out of them and
waserman and all the other great
agencies but I'm going to try to build
the biggest people sometimes hear me
like I did it earlier I'll inevitably
get a DM be like hey her in club 30
henrik's class you're trash really this
will happen they'll say you think you're
going to build [__] you think you who
do you think you are you think you're
Jim Hensen and Walt Disney and I will
reply I will reply and say no no I don't
think I'm them but I'm inspiring and I'm
aiming for it and I may not get there
but I don't even understand why I
wouldn't try to MH and I don't think I'm
delusional I think I'm capable I've won
in marketing I've won in sports I've won
in wine like I'm a
and I want to go for it I understand
it's outlandish I would even say out
loud it's unlikely to build an
intellectual property that's Disney
forget about it like it's going to take
everything I got and a hell of a lot of
things bouncing in the right way the
puck bouncing the right way for me to
get to that but why wouldn't I try right
and and so when you do start something
new like that how important is it to
know where you're trying to go like the
plan itself I think if you go super
macro at 11 years old I decided I wanted
to buy the New York Jets I believe
there's a direct correlation to the
amount of success I've had based on that
is that happening I think it is you know
I really have this weird feeling that in
20 years I'm going to pull it off like
look the Johnson family may never want
to sell it that's not in my control
what's in my control is will I have the
capacity to create that level of insane
wealth because I don't do it for the
money it does scare me that I can't get
there I don't operate to maximize money
I operate to maximize joy and so I don't
think i' even though I've accumulated a
lot of money I'm very aware that I could
have accumulated more I've done a lot of
high risk High reward investing if I
just did Real Estate in the stock market
I would have more money I'm aware of
that but if I I want to buy I want to
get to my goals my way you know I wanted
I want it I'm about the process you know
like of course I want to Hoist the stand
cup but I can only control how I show up
every day in front of the net that's
what you did and and and much like being
on a team even though I'm the
entrepreneur and even though it's all on
me I don't control the world I don't
control when inflation comes in I don't
control when you know China does this I
don't control when there's an
innovation uh that's invented like AI
that takes away an advantage that I've
built for 15 years I control my reaction
to it I can cry about it or I can say
[__] okay let's put on the [__]
helmet and go to work so that's how I
think about it listen we we're running
out of time but before I let you go I
want to leave you with this other than
the Jets winning the Super Bowl what
else are you dreaming about right
now man I love consistency and so the
Jets is the fun thing and the real thing
is I dream every day for the 10 to 15
people that are closest to me to be okay
and genuinely when you asked me earlier
are you seeing it the same way as you
did 10 years ago 20 years ago that's all
I've done always please let the people I
love be healthy and happy to the best of
like God's choices and two put on my
helmet and go to work like I don't know
anything else I keep it I'm so simple
guys I'm [__] simple it's so basic
for me
I I I just see it so clearly I'm you
know and I and I desperately want that
for everyone else and that's why I
choose to do things like this for an
hour I got a lot of things to do I do
this because I know that this is first I
admire the [__] out of you and I'm was
pumped to get to know you two I know
there's a lot of people listening that
don't know me this is enough out of my
circle yeah and and maybe have seen me
at the Garden or this and that or maybe
you've seen one thing about me and and
I'm hoping that it inspires someone to
be like to think like my whole life is
based on human saying things that made
me think differently you know I think
about that kind of stuff and so that's
that's the stuff that I like I think we
need more perspective and um and I'm
hopeful to inspire someone somebody is
literally on elliptical right now and
one of the things the three of us said
here will shape a different perspective
and my intent is for their life to be
better because of it cuz that's nice and
nice is good love that I love it thank
you so much thank you guys so nice to
have you here thank you it was
[Music]
awesome